what is happening there reject Nation
Welcome to the New Year we are going to
continue Wednesday or on episode dos
right now one how is it going it's okay
it's good I'm good Greg how are you good
that's a much different energy than
before we start rolling
that's wildly different uh anyway guys
so we'll leave a leave a like that'd be
very much appreciated also uh subscribe
and click that notification Bell before
we get notified before we get notified
so you get notified when our reaction to
the next episode of Wednesday is up here
on the channel and of course a massive
thank you to all who have become SS
rejects that stands for super sexy and
how do you become one by joining our
patreon page where you get the
full-length Reaction watch along as
we're seeing it with your own copy of
Wednesday that's where you sync up with
the time code and of course we have a
bunch of other shows over there
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included let's see how this
mystery unfolds people
usually I love dark turns
but not this one
I think we missed something I say we
doubled back sweep Creek and then call
it a night I have a feeling that
Sheriff's gonna be all right in the end
and he'll come around automatically
assume that another more student is the
murderer even though there's no evidence
that a crime was even committed I forgot
you only teach the good Outcast here
right
[Laughter]
as Fair Point
as much as you shouldn't profile people
someone is trying to cover up Rowan's
murder that's the only reason to scrub
the crime scene
is that your professional opinion is the
daughter of a murderer my father is
twice the man you are and the only thing
he murders is the occasional Opera in
the shower
you're going to want to see this
[ __ ] what Edgar Allan Poe said believe
nothing you hear
clearly nevermore's most famous alumni
picked that up here Shape Shifter have
you considered your anti-social
Tendencies might be motivated by fear of
rejection if you were to reject me right
now I would not be upset
you can't get rid of me that easily you
made it through an entire session
without trying to escape I'll take that
as a win progress
cured Wednesday
you see Dr kimbot too you should know
I'm legally required to be here two
court ordered the writers are gonna get
that Easter egg every episode he's the
monster everyone including your father
believes I made it all up you know for
the record
I believe you yeah he's the monster I
think you're right
what's Rowan's story Xavier Thorpe's
roommate you know if you had a cell
phone you could just text him and ask
him the pokeup droops for No One what is
the Poke up anyway Park Canoe Race hard
foot chase no rules so interesting
angles I've always hated the expression
right what you know
[Music]
alley-oop but when your life becomes a
twisted mystery it's time to lean into
it
she does have a page an Ancient Order
perhaps it won't be possible I'm afraid
it's been expelled
for what
never you mind faking his own death
you heard a psychic Vision didn't you
oh how do you know that I realized you
might be having them when we pass by the
accident and he knew that poor farmer
had broken his neck that's how she knew
that
it all checks out I took the liberty of
putting together a list of clubs that
have openings you need to have picked
one by the end of the day no doubt
you'll find something that tickles your
fancy last person who tickled me lost a
finger love to see that cut away
keep an eye on Roman don't light your
fingers out of his sight
she's involved too somehow I like them
as a Duo a lot let's get this audition
over with
uh what are you Alto soprano or just
Loco
oh what
was that a note only dogs can hear
this is that like Ultra soprano
[Music]
you can do better she actually showed up
never shot a bone air before only live
targets
only Pugsley with an apple on his mouth
when's the last time you saw your
roommate Robin Oh you mean the one that
was killed by a monster the last couple
weeks he's been more erratic so what's
the deal with you and Tyler
I'm sorry are you the only one who got
to ask non-archery questions here
who's doing me a favor driving me out of
town yeah word of advice steer clear
because Tyler and his friends are a
bunch of jerks there's the boy whose
life was served to him on a silver
platter you know girls in Glass Houses
should throw bigger stones
at least I'm not an elitist snob
Eugene ottinger founder and president of
the Nevermore Hummers the high of life
isn't for everyone
most kids are afraid of venomous insects
are you willing to feel this thing
Nero oh my God they're gonna have a
lovemaking scene
pouring honey all over each other
I'm not allowed to speak to anyone you
had a lot to say the other night when
you tried to kill me
tell me I was destined to destroy the
school remember you shouldn't be here
yeah back off and leave me alone
I wonder if they're gonna do more with
Christina Ritchie's character I'm
enjoying the pacing of this episode more
it's like a deliberate mystery tone
sketch it thing
[Music]
I'm about to murder this toilet
[Music]
I knew it
shapeshifter but why would he conceal it
[Music]
great music
[Music]
God I love the use of that hand
I would watch just like a one whole
episode only thing
[Laughter]
in a bathroom with no windows
a lefty wouldn't have failed me
ow what the hell was that too far can't
help it oh sh she fears that Wednesday's
psychic abilities can catch her
liability
that is a very cool Power
there's an anime character like that I
doubt Wednesday is impressed by your
tricks Mr Thorpe a minute you're a
little impressed
who can tell us the name of this beauty
dendrophylex and denii otherwise known
as the ghost orchid first discovered on
the Isle of Wight in 1854 looks like you
may have competition for first chair
Bianca oh look out greatest qualities
resilience and adaptability
it's able to thrive in even the most
hostile environments it's a metaphor for
her change the ecosystem causing the
established plants to reject it usually
because the native species is allowed to
thrive unchecked
nothing a weed whacker couldn't affix
are we still talking about flowers am I
the weed whacker clearly the plants
aren't the only carnivores in class
today
ran into your shrink she was kind of
tight-lipped about your progress that's
called doctor patient confidentiality
how about a little father-son
confidentiality what are you two yakking
about it's not real
video games cancel culture oat milk
versus soy it's a wild I pay the bills I
got a right task we talk about Mom
maybe a little bit about you too and
your freaking abusive ways your attitude
man
I'll be home late you're on your own for
dinner oh damn I was hoping we could
fire up the grill and then catch the big
game
love these warm fuzzy memories they're
making dad oh no is he somewhat
responsible for his mom's death
probably
well being a creature he probably should
have gone and Nevermore but that would
have let him you know yeah maybe he
would find his place in the world let me
just decoy
sorry I'm busy and bees totally creep me
out
why don't you ask thing oh wait you
can't because he's mad at you why is he
mad he's the one who screwed up with
Rowan all I know is that we spent an
hour giving each other mayonnaise and he
really opened up
I wanna see those fingernails
family and you would do anything for you
go apologize and I'll reconsider helping
you
circumvent your fear of bees for that
that you want hand cream nail buffer new
cuticle scissors
consider it done
I have nothing to get off of my chest
and I'm not submitting to your emotional
blackmail
that I'm going to be responsible for
something terrible
not good terrible like Ivan bad terrible
and I can't let that happen
that's why I need to find out the truth
I like how there's the werewolf in the
background
I've always had a thing for werewolf
chicks
the chance that Enid ever becomes
romantically interested in you is less
than one percent so I've still got a
shot
believe in yourself Lloyd Christmas make
it happen you ever taken a honey bath
I just don't want to get stung key is to
remain calm please detect fear but you
don't need to worry because I have a
very big smoker and I handle it like a
pro would you like to see it show show
her your smoker
you know these Woods Too Well
these are Rollins I knew it was a
cover-up
oh wow
[Music]
[Applause]
context man it sucks being roommates the
guy like that I don't usually find
students in here looking for actual
books most sneak in to make out I
accidentally walked in on two vampires
fanging
I can't unsee that
I would like to see that
have you seen this before
it's a watermark from a book I'm looking
for
I think it's the symbol to an old
student society that I was definitely
not a part of you're totally part of it
the ability to not let others Define you
it's a gift
doesn't always feel that way
the most interesting plants grow in the
shade I love that line
that purple book's got to be around here
somewhere start investigating
like comic book wall
[Music]
touching himself understood kind of get
really private
Court of owls
foreign
[Music]
you're the one who was afraid he would
do something to Wednesday isn't that why
you've been following her around like an
eager eye puppy okay why are you so
fixated on Wednesday because she thinks
she's better than everyone else
she is it's gonna be a pokeup finale to
remember yeah I hate to think what
you've got planned my game's already
started
I like to win used to love my Killer
Instinct
till you killed my heart
this short conversation gave a lot of
necessary information to work off of
Yoko was in the infirmary she's out of
the post it wasn't an accident Bianca's
behind it how do you know it doesn't
matter you and I are going to take her
down tomorrow
I love it
I want to humiliate Bianca so badly that
the bitter tasting defeat Burns in her
throat nice the past two years no other
boat has made it across the lake and
back without sinking sounds like
sabotage
there are novels in the pow cup and she
is a siren which makes her master of the
water then we just need a beater at our
own game we sail on land
your costumes in the tent
costume
yes
[Music]
Goblet of Fire this really is like a
hodgepodge of Harry potterisms
Focus what do we have here the runs of
the litter
for the record I don't believe I'm
better than everyone else just that I'm
better than you
[Laughter]
yes
jump in sexy guy
this is cool
[Music]
so you can just murder people yeah what
happens if nobody ducked
y'all got buoyed so they just need this
one merman to do the whole job yep
[Music]
thing
oh get a torpedo or something
or a harpoon
oh nice
I guess that would be the most logical
thing it's got me thinking oh my God I
was gonna murder it yeah I need you to
distract a couple of jokers
ever Dance with the Devil in the pale
moonlight
[Music]
nice
dudes are not good at all at their jobs
foreign
Oh weird time to be having a vision
different vision
oh this is different you've been
transported yeah you're like an
alternate Dimension you're in a volume
open it you were the key to what
yo what's going on
what are these slashes
[Music]
launching in their faces yes tip the
boat
damn you mermando
yeah
do it
[Music]
dude you can't we knocked him out good
hydrodynamics under there
Ben Hur that [ __ ] she's a siren can't
she get out of the boat push it can she
like manipulate all the uh or possess
everyone to block their path or
something what there are no rules here
this is the greatest moment of my entire
life
admit it you kind of got to the whole
school spirit thing
he didn't tell me it was a dark vengeful
spirit
Nevermore of course it is
[Applause]
what wisdom can you impart Poe
what are you doing down here
hiding
people keep randomly smiling at me out
there it's unsettling it's called having
your moment you took down Bianca Barclay
try to enjoy it she's been here for like
two days she doesn't really know the
extent what the full scope of the
context of that means the last time
Ophelia Hall the one that poke up
or mother Captain the team
no way I was a co-pilot
maybe you two are more light than you
think yes
did we just become best friends
sometimes
the answer is staring you right in the
face when you sit under a statue because
it's not a single riddle rather each
line is its own separate one
the opposite of moon
Sun a world between ours
sorry
leave sweep to the ground Willow it
melts in the sun ice beginning and end
never found Circle every rule has one
exception
[Music]
[Laughter]
the answer will give a sharp cracking
sound
twice
nice
[Music]
it means something there are Origins to
the snaps
what if someone was just having a
thought I was like what is it what is it
what is it
hey
secret societies
hidden libraries
my mother's staring at me in a
judgmental way I thought Gomez Adams
looks like he got shorter as he aged
[Music]
I nailed it
damn really nailed it
but the minute I inch towards the truth
luckily I'm Not Afraid of the Dark
no it's emerging again
okay
okay I could see some of that some of
that burtony I thought that one was done
like I like the directing editing that
one uh even more and uh
I assumed it was another director
I assume like oh some other like Tim
Burton set stage and then someone else
came in and then this was somebody
else's kind of steadier play on that
style yeah yeah yeah that's more
deliberate a smoother significantly
smoother I thought dude Tim Burton's
learning man he's learning how to get
better aspiring director team
up and coming
I'm rooting for it man I hope he does
big things now I really enjoyed that and
it didn't uh
like the first one the first episode I
was like very much aware of the Tim
Burton voice sure sort of resonating
throughout the whole episode and this
one really felt like its own thing yeah
I was able to just kind of kind of get
pulled into everything and feel like it
feels like it's been established for
longer than two episodes when I'm when
I'm watching this episode you know it
feels like a world that I've that I know
now and I've spent some time in which
which is nice it has it seems like it's
really
deadly set itself up and now it can just
go you know as much as last time I was
like
like the the Adam's life like yeah like
now I'm nicely hooked into the mystery
they're like
they're still putting in the history of
The Adams Family because they're linked
to the secret society yeah absolutely
and so yeah it's like you got the
mystery going and now you can just sort
of spend your time amid the suspects and
things like that and and you know be
along the deduction with Wednesday
yeah I actually I mean I know
but I hear imagine I don't know I don't
know what people's opinions are but I
personally love this episode was better
and then the last one uh I like the
first episode a lot but I I thought this
one was uh it was even sharper and more
confident more assured in almost every
breath it was taking and I really I
really thought that the Ever every angle
of it was very intriguing like it's got
some of the the tropes of the but none
of it's like annoying or uh in a way
that's distracting or befuddling in any
capacity yeah like any types of
exposition dumps that just sort of come
out of nowhere I'm like I don't really
care it's the The Whimsy and the
quirkiness of the show allows you to get
away with sort of things like that and
and I think they've I like that they've
established like a cool a world around
it you know of how Nevermore is a it's
cool but it's not like it's like what
goes on at that school sure is part of
the secret element to the outside world
but the World Of Monsters And Ghouls and
Mayhem and all that jazz is still
is is everyone knows about it every
everyone's aware of it you're like it's
not something that's a mystery the
sheriff's not like you're crazy that
doesn't exist yeah you know it's
something to investigate yeah it's just
something better left you know in the
shadows or away from you know polite
societies yeah I'm cool with that and uh
Jenna Ortega's Wednesday as she's
evolving and growing like I think the
journey that they're setting her up for
to form connections to form stages of
vulnerability to
develop uh actions that are based off of
empathy and concern and doing something
good as opposed to just delighting your
oneself in something that's uh the the
trick side to trick-or-treat or treating
yourself to some tricks I really I
really really think that that seems to
be a smooth build in that direction and
the way the cast is fleshing out too
like I like The Supporting Cast even
more this time around like first episode
as it probably ought to be because it's
Wednesday it's like feels like the Jenna
Ortega show and everyone else hears I I
thought even their even actors who I
thought were kind of maybe not fully
doing it for me I thought everyone here
did a really great job and of course the
mystery of Gwendolyn Christie as oh you
must be the real villain
surprised
I'm surprised the thought never went
there of
she's the suspect
yeah I mean they I guess I guess the way
they present her is like suspicious and
adversarial but maybe not the most I
don't know if you're coming into this
with like your I'm gonna outsmart in the
movie brain I feel like there are
reasons to assume that she's like too
obvious of a suspect
but uh I'm curious I'm curious to see
what the full scope of things is because
right now yeah it's like I know she's
definitely involved but I don't know if
she's necessarily like the monster from
the woods I think you're probably still
right that it's probably what Tyler is
that his name uh it's probably still him
but there's got to be a bigger I feel
like there will probably be some sort of
dual thing where there's like a
misunderstood monster element because
that's a heavy theme already and you
know what better to confront to your
Outcast characters with than a greater
Outcast but then also yeah there's got
to be a different sort of conniving you
know string pulling secret society
aspect and I feel like that's what when
Gwendolyn Christie ultimately plays into
well I mean she there they have lines of
dialogue that sound intentional for
Wednesday to not suspect Tyler sure
yeah like you don't think it's weird
just talking to my parents no I do it
all the time or some [ __ ] like that yeah
uh I I forget how the exact exchange
goes down
but the way when she dismisses it it's
like
well you know if you think about this
for a second Wednesday would he be
normally maybe question why you're doing
it and she said too that she knows the
the creature was trying to protect her
and Tyler clearly wants like I I think
they're you know this the setup of like
who's the killer in the woods but really
it's not a killer yeah it's uh actually
a protector it's a protector who's
supposed to protect Nevermore so yeah
I'm thinking that he's the killer of the
kid but uh you know when he found his
monster ability something went wrong
that led to uh the death of his mother
and the dad resents his son for that
yeah yeah that seems about right maybe
he ripped her up accidentally yeah or
maybe he she died giving birth to him I
feel like that's happened in a few Tim
Burton things well they're doing a lot
of
um they're doing a lot of different
genres being spliced into one here
because while you got your Gothic horror
tale that you're telling you also got
your high school tail yeah you got your
Hogwarts story yeah you're very awkward
young adults yeah Hogwarts down to the
plant yeah herbology this is Sprout yeah
that's a sprout you have the you have
that quality and they have the
supernatural mystery uh you have the
investigation that young adult Nancy
Drew type of quality I I and I think
with everything they're meshing together
it's surprisingly flows
I can't think of something that's not
none of those categories all those
categories are working for me yeah and
sometimes I find myself going well this
part's not really doing it for me this
part's not really doing it for me you
know I'm not like necessarily
I'm interested in all the characters I
wouldn't say I'm like emotionally hooked
into all the characters yet I'm sure on
the second episode and we're cutting
around to a lot but I'm very much
intrigued and I'm enjoying it and I
think every every category they're doing
is great but to me the the heart of this
uh are the scenes with thing and and
Wednesday those scenes are so well done
and
like yes one of the biggest tropes it's
like the Trope of when someone's talking
into the phone but you don't hear the
other person the phone so the person
that you're watching is like repeating
everything yes the person on the other
side is yeah
like they reiterate literally like
no I'm not this this this this this is
what do you yeah you did this and that
yes I know you said this this but here's
my response to this he needs the
McGuffin by what time so I I like I like
the scenes though a lot I understand you
need that information to come through
and again it's the it's the it's the it
keeps coming it constantly comes back to
tone and if you if you nail that tone
those scenes are fine because there's
you can't have things speak it would be
a cheat to have things speak
but yet you can feel the voice of thing
yeah I love that so much it feels like a
full character right yeah really really
really does and it's like that animated
character animated sidekick character
buddy if it's like a pet or an animal or
something like that or the cute adorable
thing and so I like how they've
you know like they're they've obviously
like this doesn't feel who Wednesday is
to
um distant from though I I it's very
easy for me to Fathom how we got the
interpretation we know of Wednesday over
the generations to how we put her into a
modern day story that focuses on her
like it still feels like Wednesday
Addams to me sure
and thing
they've really to me that's probably the
biggest surprise is like the life as
much as I'm enamored by uh Jenna
Ortega's performance the thing is the
character that they've really done
something more to really Elevate him to
it to a whole new kind of character I'm
endeared too sure and that strikes a
really great chemistry like to me the
best chemistry she has is with this
freaking hand it is in a lot of ways and
I'm and I'm really surprised by that
because it's not like it's not giving me
a tingle about the Nostalgia of thing uh
it's it doesn't work it doesn't play on
Adam someone doesn't for me you're not
an Adam's Family Guy nope John haha nope
uh yes thank you for that I enjoy it for
that laugh I enjoy Adam's family uh so
what I'm saying is like none of my
praise is from a nostalgic love yeah you
know and I I'm I'm pleasantly surprised
I'm not gonna lie I wasn't too
interested in watching the show
okay okay because yeah I was like was
not itching to watch this show I was
like nervous to start it because of the
investment yeah so yeah you're like
apathetic yeah not that I thought it was
going to be bad or anything but I I've I
I wasn't I wasn't interested and like I
never watched the trailers I didn't get
I just didn't care and it was strictly
due to like the amount of patrons being
like a ghost on Wednesday yeah the
biggest show ever on Netflix yeah that
still didn't matter yeah I'm sure sure
and then that's why we relate to it so
I'm surprised by how well this show is
working for me because it is very very
it is a really really enjoyable show and
and and even things that feel like
derivative of other works that we keep
referencing I don't care I don't mind I
I I I I I if anything that's the
nostalgic word to please tell me yeah
I'm like oh it's kind of like Goblin
fire uh like that I can I weirdly I'm
like sure because even something like
Goblet of Fire it's a lot of Harry
Potter's inspired by other works of
fantasy sure and the tradition carries
on yeah yeah absolutely absolutely and
so I I like the I like the sequence too
um the game The Cup game oh the PO cup
yeah yeah it's all rowing the the water
and land capture the flag challenge what
I would want from the show to do a tad
bit more is the
a notice in like the Edgar Allan Poe
scene at the end when she's doing the
puzzle solving of the clues I want to be
there a little bit with Wednesday and
like try to guess yeah and get it wrong
like I don't mind getting it wrong I
just want to kind of have a moment to go
is it enough okay yeah I want to be part
of the deduction yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I am craving for the mystery
unsolving to be a tad harder for her
sure because it seems like when she
locks onto a Target she gets it well
yeah yeah and you want the mystery to
feel more like a broadly encompassing
thing rather than a linear path of like
here's one question and then we find the
next breadcrumb and like that's not a
bad thing to do but but yeah something
that we involves the audience in the
game
yeah something that that has and maybe
it will hopefully by the end maybe we'll
look back and go oh man there were so
many pieces laid out that we didn't
really you know realize were even puzzle
pieces at the time but as of now like
the core mystery feels a bit linear and
a bit
you know straightforward yeah they're
kind of just giving us stuff yeah
they're just giving you the unfolding in
a way that I'm interested in uh but not
in a way that
that's like Glass Onion or something
yeah yeah you wanna I mean to me it's
part of the fun of the mystery genre is
can you figure it out too yeah yeah you
want to be along yeah I mean you want to
be alongside your hero as as like semi
Cipher you know yeah deducing along with
them but when when she's deciphering the
Edgar Allan Poe
um riddle
it's just started like overlapping and
kind of montaging through it and I was
like oh no I wanna I wanna be there I
don't know I wanted to see if I can
figure it out yeah yeah exactly
absolutely so a little bit of that is
some something that I think could
enhance the mystery angle as part of the
suspense and uh the intrigue
but overall though it's a really
enjoyable I think it's an extremely
enjoyable show it is I mean like yeah
it's you know obviously Jenna Ortega
like you said her and thing or or well
like they feel like family they feel
like family which is a nice really nice
thing and and yeah there's something
about his presence that's able to bring
certain things out of her that I think
is wise not too heavy speaking character
do
um and yeah I feel like I'm kind of
right there with you in that this is
doing a bunch of things at once and I
like all the things I'm looking at this
and yeah it's like even if you say Harry
Potter you're like well it makes sense
so put Wednesday in a Harry Potter
situation that's fine okay why not sure
uh you know she's already been to camp
like famously in you know family values
and they're clearly drawing from a lot
of that stuff too but uh like yeah
everything they're choosing to do is
like cool I like the idea of this and
everything is brought to life well by
the you know production designer overall
minus yeah maybe like a couple wonky CG
moments or whatever good cast all around
I think of appealing cast all around and
then the thing is yeah you
I feel like most of the things it's
doing it's doing all right it's doing
fine and they're all Charming enough
together that I like what's happening
here and if I get really critical I'm
like none of these things are especially
unique to what the genre is that they're
playing on or the Trope it is that
they're playing on and that's you know
kind of what I'm waiting for now is is
I'm not like the show isn't at a
disadvantage I'm very much enjoying it
and I will happily keep on going at this
level of enthusiasm but it would be very
gratifying to see some of these elements
transcended like damn that was a really
like you like you kind of brought up
like really intriguing solid mystery oh
man like you know I was able to crack
parts of it and stuff like that you know
like that would make it that much more
engaging
um but you know
we're a quarter of the way in now you
know so I don't necessarily expect like
a huge Evolution necessarily but uh but
yeah like that's that's the one thing is
like if they could just really put some
creative stamps now on this convergence
of ideas that they have I think that
could make the show really sing but as
of now yeah it's like I went in with
like cautious optimism you know I'd
heard pretty good things overall and uh
and I'm pretty pleased at the moment so
I'm happy about that like I'm happy to
really only have complaints if I'm
thinking about them you know if I'm
trying to find them yeah yeah yeah
yeah overall I thought this I mean to me
pacing and is a big deal I just like
hanging out here and yeah you know I
like me I like being part I think I
think what the the show does really well
is good world it's a good World building
because I like that it's all focused on
this one school
a little bit on the outskirts of the
school
but you get the sense that the whole
world is aware yeah and and I I I so I
feel like you can really
I like keeping it in this location but
you know thinking like way future
you can do an expansion and you can
really create a sirenic [ __ ] Universe
yes
mortician Gomez origin story let's go
you can really go off here uh but yeah I
think it's a really good show
um I'm I'm I I see the
I see why this
has has soared there's been a lot of
Addams families projects that haven't
really soared yes and this one really
soars here right now is the time for
this iteration of The Addams Family yeah
it works yeah it works it feels like a a
cool young adult novel yeah yeah exactly
yeah and Wednesday iconic
all right guys well uh keep a lookout
for a reaction of Wednesday episode
three
um tell us what you thought about our
reaction I think it's weird just be like
what'd you think about this episode I
feel like I'm already done with the show
it's kind of a bland thing it's not like
a Monumental episode you know yeah and
the way in which you know if I assume a
lot of people binge this so people are
going to be like which was episode two
exactly what happened even though I just
rewatched the reaction that was her day
was leave a like
subscribe check us on patreon thank you
for all who's showing your support uh
we'll see you all around thank you
[Music]